>>HEDIN TLE TSEIT ISNHI TS
COMI WEERE WKHERVE AOO BKSRE
SOATND A W FCHORAN MY OFSE THE
OFOCEFI TEA APP IRNHE TEA NR
FU
NRETU Ooo BV.kT
♪
♪♪
♪ ♪
♪
>> GD EVINENG,VE E.BORYDY
ADMI' G LEV EXE DTICUVERECIRTO
OFHE TPLEME-EMA ENU STRCKER
INTCEEROR H'MON TEDOEL W
MEO
TYOU OURIN FALALIR VTUNT EVE
OF
HE TUM SR.ME
REBEFOEGE W BAN IIN W TO TNKHA
THUNDRS OFHO T OANUSDSOUF Y
R
OS AOMCRS THERYOU CNTHEND A T
ILDRL WN JLOIUR OALIR VTU
COYUNMMITNGRO PVI LHA TTGRNEAIN
ANINNG EAGN EGVET A AIS D
E
S MAKEON SUSTRR.GE
IT IINV YEOUO T CCKHEUT O OUR
FU
AL CLLAT O OOGNSI WUREB.TE
BWILL BAC INERCT OOBO T BINEG
WSTMEERERE FRLAIYRO PUD
.
SEPLEAGA AINOO SN.
EENWH WEDLA PNNON THTIG PGRROAM,
AICON CFLHAT TT ISON GE ON SO
LOHA TTOS ALMIST DEDPEAPAR
HEOMFR TNGVE ENI NS,EWHE TN
ENESPRIDNBIT DE P OLEULDUT ALL
AM
SICERA'SRO TOPNGEA LDI TO- -
LE
TINADGOIG TONHTVE ENT AND A
ETWNE S OFIOUE QST.NS
WERE AOR HON THARAT C
IG
LOWHITNS JCKOIONS U THTIG TO
USDISC AS NIONBLDIN PGJEROCT
O
EDOM TOLU FAI A LUTDAI ON I
HITEW NES BK,THE
ISGHAFANAPNTA PHIS"ER W YCHOU
CAASUR PCHEIG R NHTOWSI UNG THE
LIHEN I THA CTW.IN WDO
ANGAESNVTIEPVETI R FTEORROR
WAETH "ONINSHGTOS PANT" C CRAKE
OMSHA CH WEITHE TBA GLOL OAR WN
M ORRRIS 2NCSIEND100 AS ANE O
SUOUF O JMALRNISIGHE
NOHO.RS
GHTONI W HTE BLIL IE
N
ERCONV WTISAONHIT HISAGOL CLE
A
OSRLOZ LA,ADHE TZEUL PIT
NNE-IZWIONGIN NNCTFIIOOO BKRPR
ICCRIT
AVOU Y HEUE Q PIOSTNS YASLEEOU
TFREEO PTOST I INHE THA C
T
WIT OWND AE.YTANIM
WE T GLETOS A MYANS A
POLEIB.
OWDAN NELE PASOI JNN I WNGCOELMI
R
GAIHI WOCTLKND ASAR CLO
LO.
NK T>>HA
HA>> T V YNKOUCHY ERMU
IS SH ANOR HON TO BERE,IT
N
C IDLDOUEOT N BOR ME EITXCED
TO IE BONN CRSATN WHITY M
GULLCOEAIG CERAOCHI WTLHOK W
I'EDDM AIRRO FMFA ART AHE
HI"WASPOTONGN OR"ST F MYAN
ARYES.
OD TIS DSSCU A BKOOND A A
ECSUBJT TTHAOULDEOT N B MEOR
TI
NDLYME AALRU CCIN IHI TS
NTMOME.
JU TO OTA SRTFFHE T A'SRE
ONCBUHAT EFQUNIO IT WANO TSK A
YOU A TUTBOHE BOO BUTIR FST
OF IN THEAT DEBVEE O TRSHIAR W
ANOW,E WSERKI LOOACNG B OKNT, I
HIT'SODAR THHE SIKHE T NIOOTN
MEATTH AOSCARI LTORIS H WK.
ALETH TSANIB IK BACN I.OW PER
YE
YOURRESIIDNTDE BGH SENIN
,LOOKE WOM ACCISPLHHATE W
TNTWAEDOM AOCC
ISPLH.
WEEF D aTEEADAQAl-EDN I
ANAFGHTAISN.
DOW HOOU S TARQUETHA
ENFFDIER?CE
TSWA I PVE ERESIOSBLO TLY TRU
HINWI TS WNDAR AHA W WTHIT
WITGIN IAVECTLLUAY LKEOOD
I
?KE
>>RESEHO AIOUE QSTAR,NS CS,LO
UL SWEHOSKVED' A AED LGONIM TE.
TA CORERURLYIN OEA LRSDEUL SHO
S
T WKHAEREY THEIN TRY TGO
LICOACMP.SH
H IITSDAROR FEN BIDO TAR SQUE
ESETH RTULH WIT WETHA HAID W
E
MPACCOHASHLI W S WTEETUT O T
O
WGET YNHEOUEE SGE IMAFS OHE T
TAAKNBA TG OR THEHO WLE
TRCOUNOP SY,WONTGIN I TOHE
AI CT ORIN ABLOBEERFT.S U.
LOOTRPS TVEEA,REHE'SO N
TIQUEST TONHAHE TTE UNIDSTA STE
TANDHEHA AFGER GNOV HENNMTEAV
LO
STHI TSICON CFLT.
TFROMME CHEOM PSNTSPECVE
ATHEY ARESIC SKOY TSS A TYHE
CO
OPDUL H. FEOR
BUETHUESTSNIO IHA WT CAN WE
OPEHO TPLCC AOMH?IS
IEONKHI PEPLBEEM REMK BRACN I
20 TFT AERHEMBEP STE
1ER1
CKATTA TSHEHO WSEUR PPO OF
GO
OGIN TAR IHA AFG WSTNIAN
O
KTT AACl- aEDQAA, WASO T
INELIMHEEAT TTHR TEAM FRO
AEAL-QIS, DATHLLO GBARIER TRO
R
OPOU S THA TTOUYHE CN'LDT
CA A OYUT MNYE TSTROERRI
ATSCKGAINST UHE TTENID
ESSTATTSAR TGEGAR O ALLSTIN ASIE
AR TNDHEOR W.LD
INNIFG AHAEANST WER WERE P
YTT
SUCCSFUL TIT WHITTHA WHENHI T
FI M STIXTHS.
2PR AILUS200 JTBO AUTLL AF O
-QalSDAAE IRSEA LDEAD HEE BN
CA KEDUR,LEILD O HREAV FDLE
ISGHAFAN
N.TA
RTHEYLLEAY DN'T HEAV A
LENESCEFTTEF A TERHEIN SPRG
OF2.00
M FTROT THAOI PNTOR FRD
HE'SAT WSI MNISEP CONRE
STODTE TET S INRE PYTT
AKLICY, HAS AOT L OFHE TU
DO SNTMESORWHO FHI TS BK,OO
VE
NT BRYLUEO,LY PIDE PLSA WE
FLOSTUSOC,EC BEAMNC U WARLETHA
ROUOA GNDLS AEC OBJ WVETISEER
BOARIL MITNDYIL AICOL PITLYAL
RAD ANSTLLGITECA F AY,ND TORHE
LAEA9 1 Y WRSEAV HEER NEV
BALRELYBLNEE A TEO S OETUT
LYICPLIT WHA WT AEREOP H TGINO
IN ASTHAFGNI.AN
HIEON TSI PNGREIDNTDE BNT PENOIS
TO AOT L ISHE TTH DEAF OSA OMA
BI
LAD00N I 21N WHEE H WAS
EDKILL PN INISAKTAND AEN BID
YS THAAS W T LHETAS TENGHI WSA
EDWANTO TPLCC AOMH.IS
TH CS ILYTAERIN IRU TENMS TER
F
HE T ORINALL GOAF O
DIGTLANINEDl- aQA T BAUTNHE
AT RSESHE TUE QIOSTNHAF O WT
WE TLLEAY TINRYGOOM ACC
IH
HERFO TEAEN T YRSIN SCEHE T
D W>>HY T YOOUNKHIME ACARIN
BERADS TIEELVEYHEAN CAK REMLE
E
HEOF TNT COU OESRI,ERTH
SO
S,ETCIIEFORA TNS THE
TIPOLI
?CS
HEWHETS IRT'AMIE VTNR ORA IQ OR
GHAN
TAISN.
ACIN FSI PT,REUSNTDE B
H,
IDPRESAMT ENOBSI PA,RENTDE TMP
AYLAL SHE TYOU WLD N EOTAGNGEN I
ONNATINGILBUDIND YHE TY, DID
OVER0.EA YRS
Y?WH
>>HAT' AS
R
A GLLEAYUEDOO QION
DAN I TNKHI ONEHA TURT O LDEEARS
TVEHAN'RENS AWE
HEEER T WASNE IEWERNTVIN I
ETHHA AFG PSTNIAN WERAPSHIT A
FO
AVERRM N SYLEAAD ME JFREFEY
WGEEGRSKE WHOOR ADTHE THI WTE
EHOUSHEN O TAT NNAIOLS CLDOUE H
STER UFNDUSH ANDMA OBA AND
HEER SNDVE I ASTHAFGNI, T,
HANDSE REAIT TDHAAM SE
ESQU
ONTI.
WSAID W DHYOHIE TENK W CAN
MSFANORTIOC SIEE LESIK TS?HIR
DWHY WOEE TAKN OHE TSENO EOURMS
STASKS A ANT COU?RY
HE SAIDT ILL REAYS, GET IS A
ONESQUTIUMF O H PSYOLOG
W DYONK TEHIE W CANO DHI TS,Y.H
LICOACMPSE TSHHEHI TS?NG
ONYWH D'T WE TEAK A
ATE SACP K
ANONESQUTI OOM SESE TFHEIC BAS
S
ONMPSUTI
E WATERE TGNKHIINGRY TINO T
TRORSFM NOTUS JTERE CAT A NEW
GGHAFANENEROVNM A NT,EWHAFGN
ITINST,IOUTNSNUT B I WOM SESAY
TRORSFMFG ANHAOC S
TYIE.
TYETASSHI W AOU CRYNTHA TT
ANERAMICW KSNEER VYIT L AETL
O
G GOINNDIN AE WEV NEREA ROTYLL G
A  GERTTSPRA OFHA WTNFG AHA
CU
AURLTEIE SNDOC WASIK LE.
ETHERERRE A VEWY F. U.S
OF
SCIFIALHO SAK THE
,UANGGEINPE SAK T AGTHEFG AN
WLIA NK0CHHI 2EA YRS.AT LER
IHENKHI TNS AR IRI HUBS.
EN TD TONK THISEEC BAUE WRE AWE
MTHEOWTOS PFUERLNAT NION IHE T
IRLWODAN MAYY WHAS TTE W CAN
NYDO AINTHG.
SISTH IHE TARIL MITDS MYIN.ET
ULETH CSRETU I AOAN C-DREUL CTU
SAND
RIPIT.
STHEY C WAYEAN DONY AINGND
IMNYMA TES TT'HASDM A BABIRLEUT
SO PMETIS NPLEOEODEE T AAK TE
STAC BKND AEE SHA WTS I
ISREALCTIE? HER
CANOU TSLEL U AEIT LTL BIT
AB TTHEEN G OISESFHISK? BOO
IUSCAEE SNOMS WAY INK THI T
E
INORIGTO SRYTS I IFELS
RYLAVETO TBO AUTHE WAYHA TT
ARETH WAS W PTESEROCU ADNDT THA
F
SCIFIAL OPO SKE DRIDOT N
LYBLPUIC APE SAKUTBOT I.
E. S>>UR
LIOOLL A GRI SDTO ITTARTED
U
WIT TH AIVIP T F YERSEAGO A.
AOU DBT CTAONCT OFIN MEAI SD I
D HEARATTH TSHID KINF O OBSRE
FEGELRA AALYNC CHEDLE T
IIAECLORPENSCTALEN GER FOR
ANAFGH HTAISNONEAV CCTDUED AN
IETEINRV RWIW THYENECTL RIRETED
NEGEICLRA M FELHANNLY, AODAY
Y
K INNS ODINFIOOT NOR FUSOR
BE AGIT POLALICRE EXTUTSTMI B
BACKN 2601 JAD HTUSET REDIR
HEOMFR TIL M DARITY HINURGIS
ARAREE
WHEASEL WL KWNNO,AD H AYRE PTT
O
UT RODEP MIOATNYITILAR
INCEIGLLENND A YETEEVE ORSN
ANATO U.S INTNCLIELGE
IN
ANAFGH FTAISNUM AOR NFRBE O
YES.
RD HIEAHI TSYGE ANCAS HT ION C
D
ITHISEWERNTVIIT WH F ANNLYND AT
MEE THTI HEAS W I TNHE HESDLEAIN
FORTUP SPOF ORU TMPND A GEONO T
H
VE CEON SIONTNGANKE FOKR UP,
LOP,ER H UUT ABOEA HLIERTH K
E
IER WETEERNTESDUT ABO AEW NS
PEECTPEIVBO AUTT WHA HEAI SD
AB
FGTOU AANNIHAST WO S IUSAS JT
U
OUI FND OUTHA TTPE INSORCT
GED,L RAHAACN I FDU CT,ONEDCT
NTISTH IVIEREW WHE AEDSKOR F A
R
PTSCANRITF O I B TAUECSESHI
OTDHA NEE BNE  MAD.BLPUIC
ET RSTHCTNS IPEER GORENAL
SFIOFCEURDAI SE,DNHO SUL B'TE A
PRENM,LE S Y IDNROUSTEQ RUE IN
WRG.IN
TONGLO SRY,HO SRTS ARU TMP
DTEARDOELL I TNHE PSEULND A
A
BECA N HMEISLIOATNAITEC SURFNN
YAEL
SEVIR,HE TNS I GCTPEOR
EDDENIY MEQ R ASTUE WNDEND EED
IN HUPAV G TGO TRT COUHE T
GTSHWAINT PONOSILED AED FREOM
NF IONMAORTIITAW LSUSEEC BAU
ONROU CSNUTIOU IHI TSLI PSUBC
ATFOINRMN.IO
TONALG I WHEAYEA HRD TTHA
RECSPTOALEN GERLLCT AUA HYAD
DO AHI TSARS P OTF ARIG BGE
PR
ECOJTDAL CLESO LESNSRN LEAED
ISWAEWERNTVIED ORVE00 4PL PEOE
WH IER WEDOLNVVE TN I WHENAR I
O
AC CMEAPROYIT FER GMENSAL AND
OMDIPLHISAT WTESE HOU OICIA
DAN AIDRSOR WKE FOR AGR PROAM
EDCALLNSES LSOEDEA LRNHERE
RYREWE TOGIN TT SORF OSS ASES
EOATWH PHOEPL TERHTUG W
TAKSTEST HE BADNEE M IENMI
ISGHAFANN.TA
LLTUNARAT TYHATAU CGHY
ATIONTNECAU THISAS W
011620-2 PAN7 D TPLEOE TUGHOHT
A
W WRAS DDIINNGUTNOW B WE
THGHT TAY MBEOUSHI W A BLDE
AYODGO WO T G OETURRM ASUN AROD
NAJOURALSTLIICS TLYHISMSS AESTEN
T WOFHAOID D G IRO WNGN
AFN.ISANTA
G L>>ON STO SRYGARTHO A WEAD
OTO G TOOU CIN ARTGA AECON
DTI
.ME
TOSPINECER GRENLL RALEA N DYID
T
DOCU BNTMES WUTELT UYATIMELE
PRL.AI
K TITOOHR TEEEA YRSUT BE WER
AB TOET GBO AUT0 200AG P OF
ETHES AOT NESNDNS TRAIPCRTSF O
TH
EESNT ISVIEREW.
TH RER WE BLLEAY
NTLU.
TA LOF OHE T PSEPLEOEGA AIN
AMS,ADSSORALEN GERSE WER
WYISANGN' DEIDW KTNOHA WT WE
WE IOI DNGNNIFG AHAANST.
WEN' DIDE HTAV AEGTR SAT
N' DIDAVT H AEAM C PIGPANN..WE
WE KN'IDT WWNO WTHAREE'.OI DNG
NDWE E -ED-N' DIDTER UNDAND
THOCE STYIE.
RIETH C WCITISMST BASLI AINERGT
A
ETOM CPLEASON CTRM FTROT WHA
IN P ITNLICVERHE T
EDPRECECGIN DE.AD
T TATHAOI PNTHE WN YOUE W HAD A
EWODGO NRY SSTOND A WEEDEC DID
TOTEAK I IONT P ATTREY BIG
PRT.EC
EM DINEC19R BE20UB REPSHLIEDHE T
SEES, PLS AO ATEOSD TLLHE
NO ASNDVINT IERSEW WE O
AN
OUIN C SRTOEOPLELD COU S FEEOR
M
TH.LVSEES
T GR EA TOUABTK BHEOO I TNKHI
IS NTOTNL OYAP CRETUS WTHAOU Y
NELEAROU TDHR L TGHHESONS
ECOJT ANDHA WT YOUEP RTORN I
ASE TH"WNNGHITO BOS PT"
E'ERS A SIEERSF OUM DOCTSENTH
ABDAN CNDSLE A OLRARIIS HTO
ESN
DEW N MLERATIAHA TTEA RYLL
EATEN ESVE ARUL FLEREIC PTU
.N
NE O OFHOSE TTHAYEA RLL
MRUSTCK IENDI REANGOOHE T BK
YO MAV HEFYAN O TSE M
OSEM
DFROMALONDELUM RSFD,HE TAT LE
RUDON  WFEMSLD T WHOASEN DHEEF
E
YETCRARHET A TE TIMF O/1 91.
D ANEAOTW Y IRSONTHE T W,ARIK LE
24 IEA YRSONT THE WARE' HS
LACOMPININING  THESE,EM MOS
ALTEINRN I,AV HE NOIS VYILIBIT
TO T BADUY G AS.RE
ICWHHS IEM REKAARBL TOHI TNK
THOUABT  D YATOU'TONYEA RLLNO KW
TWHOMY EHENES. I
ETSO LE M PUTT THAO T
OU Y.
WWHO T OASFHENE EMY TN IHEAR W
IN ASTHAFGNI?AN
DA-QalAE T,HE T,IBALANSI IS? K
WWHOOEER TOU CRTELUM RSF TDHE
UYDBA GT TSHACAME ARIAS W
NGGHFITI?
>>.IG RHT
IT LNDOUS SEIK APLIMEST QUEN
BUE W'T DON WNO KW THOHE BAD
GU
E. WYSER
WELDN' DISSHNGTIUI
HE.
SAS IEFDAI BEORT AIR FST ITAS W
RCLEAEDl- aQA I WAAS. ANNY
TH TEHEAD B GSUYUT BY BHE T
SF RMEUMRODEL WTEHA TEMT MO
DA-QalAEONAS W GE IN
ISGHAFANUTNTA BERE W WLL SETI
FIEONGTI PE.
WEEERIG FINHTGEEO PPLT THAE W
'TULCODNSLW AAYSTND UERHADAN W
T
R THEITITIMOVASONER W WE,THA
OROUGRP RKET NWO WHE TREEER A
PA
I ORTFT.
WES TADHIM TERHE TAL TAN BUT
THANAL TIBEDOV CERHEN I T
ERNUMBNSF O I GGEURNT CUPROSAN
MEMESOTIY TSHE CER WELMIRINA
NEKSORORGG SMURERSLE A
PE A WLEHORET JUSPP OEDO
THEEO PPLHAN I CERGN
ANAFGH
TAISN.
UMAS R SELSFDHODAI WHERE A TAD B
YSGU?
ITHIS ASISIM SPLCTIIE VWF OHE T
ICAMER SANETN IFG AANNIHAST
.TH
EREER WD GEOO AUY GS BAD
.YS
HATTH'S L WOWETKOO AT IUT B THE
LEPROB A WMAS L OOTF THE G
DOO
,GUYSCAME ARIE LNSIKO TNK THI O
ELOURSTSVE A GOO GDUTSUY BUR O
NESLI I THE AHAFGNOV GT,NMERENAL
WESTHELORD CORPTRU
MEVEGORNIC ONTFF TLSIA,ERYHE W
O
AY ATLWSO S GDOOND AHE
LAPOPUIDONTI DIKTN' LM TEHEER VY
U
.CH
ETH BADS GUY WASUS J STNDRTHOHA
ANFOR HONEYO WHOS I S AINOTG
US
WTELD COU AAYLWSEEF DINIR THE
MOS.TIVAON
TH PAS W A TBLROEMNITHA UDTE
ST NEV FIGEDURUT O
WA-FSTORRD AUTBO5 1
EA5 1 YN E
LDMSRUFERO WTEHA TEMO, THE
COWAR RANMMDE AND IHI TNK 2701
LNEGERA COH JNLPBAMEL
AS W
IFTESTEFNGYI BONEOR C AESGRS
NE
WASSK AEDY BAT SENFSOR I THE
NLITABAN S I IE?TH
EEAR WINIG FHT T TGHE?IBALAN
GEAMLRA CELPBLIN KDF
ST AREMEDSE PNDAU ADNDN' DID
T
FINAEYLL H NAI SDEIOUE QST ANND
ROU CRINTES IDE THE TIBALAN
S
TOT NHEMY ENE.
WEIN TRERY TGOON RECLECIIT WH
H
IT PEMOL.ALICLY
R IENN DENECTT'SAY IN BSEE
VESION CFUHE,NG TGE IMAE CSOM
AFROMSTHAFGNIT TANHA
THE
BATALIN T OKOORVET THA'SHE TRE
BEENOO CONRAPETIT A AIT MIL
YR
LLEVE BWEETEN. U.SEN G AALERSND
ALETH T
ANIB.
WE TEN STHE CIATOIR DEC TROK TAL
TOALHE TANIBRSEA LDEP
LYCERENT.
E'THERUE AS QIOSTN I'MOINGO T
THIS TEG BSHEUE Q WIOSTN,HYE WER
IGWE F TINHTGIB THEALORAN F THE
LA0 2RS YEA
YRL O ITAK M
E
M
ENESAK S T A
THEIB TALOVAN GTNMERENAD H
aSTHOEDAQAl-EDRI POR TO00 21
DAN A RUSEFEO TE GIVP U BIN
LA
'SHE TREUEO N QIONHAT
TASN BAWADLL AIE WH
BAE-QDA WUTE SRTTAEDUT O
WI
S TTHHI WAR WHIT THEHT FIG
AG
aNSAITAQAl-EDEND A W EEDND
ETUP GRANGTI DNTEDGG I OOR
IN OINRTGESSEURLVN I A
UNNGLO-RIVNGNI C WILARN I
ISGHAFAN WNTAREHEE RLLEAY
DIER U'TND TANSTDFE DHEIFNTRE
NSCTFAIOER VY WL.EL
>> OHE,NE T OINRRVEIDGTHR TUSF O
TH TOO BKAKTHA MTES I SO
PO
RFULS TTHA YOUASON CTR
TTH
VA PERITEMP ISSIOF O A
SE D OESFTILOIPMACND A
TAMILI N ARYNDRNGOONVE
NTML
ERLEADOL ISNVNDVE I ASTHAFGNI
I
P TTHHELIUBC DTILAECRANDSON A
ETHNO EOURMSTR CONETTAS BENWE
.THEM
OUAS YONEN MTIEDAR E OLYN,
COEDARO T IGHQ-RAAFNISANTAAS W
LE-CSOALD GDOO, WAR TNE O
TH
E  MATAD
NSSEE.
'STHATHE WREEDl- aQAA WASN WHE
EREYTH PETRPEAT/1HE T 91
CKATTA
WSOHYID DIAFF OICL FLSEE THE
EDNE T LOIE OR SN TAI M
N
ORSUPP T FTOR WHEARHE TEA LST
IN
YIAITLLADOM SE SPOUPRT BOT
A
LYONTIALNTND A IONNAERTILYAL?
R>> I GLLEAYUEDOO Q WIOSTN,HY
TULWODEEYHE FLHE TEE ND B
E
IAINITEOYLL PEREPL WEHE BDIN IT.
NCKBA I00 21 PSEULDHO SWEE MOR
ANTH0% 8F OCAME ARINSPO SUPEDRT
ETH MYITILAR OPETION ASNDAR W
HA AINFG.STNIAN
AG W INTASEE SN AS AAR W OF
SELFEFEN,SE AUS JTAU CSEUT B
THCI P'SREHELYSE TSO REAHYN W
EAROU LOURSDE CN'LDTRI BNG
TH TLVSEES BOELU BNT AND
WNEHOSTHINHE T WSNGEEROT N
GOGL WELSEEC BAUHE TTE UNID
TATSTES WUGHOHTONE WS THIAR W
IBACK2. 2N00
THANAL TIBALHE T TADANIB HN BEE
E
FVEMODMRO PEROW.
al
AE-QDAAS W GE.
BTHEDMHUS AATISINTRADNIO H
ESYIANTLLREEC DLA VD.TOICRY
AF
DSRWTEAR O,NERI AMENCA
IDPRESHAT,EN WER GTENHA,AL W
TSE
YETCRARTAF O S ONCUS JT
HETMI T AYREYLO SWLOS LHEGIN T
TWARMETHA A TCARINS WUGHOHTE
ODNE ANDHA TTAS W SNEES A THEA
JU?AU CSE
WBONODYOTSAN TDM AIT FLUAIRE
TANER H I AITUAON LEIK
TH
I SATO STRTTAED OUTS A A
CECTLUANDMO T AT TITHAHI TSNG
WEOT NNG GOIEL W BL THE
LO WEREER WEHE TRE AND THE
TEPDEERHO DHEIS GSTNEYRE WODHE
ROU LDEEARSER WAYE SGINRE WE'
MAGR PNGROHAS,ES THET T
TESTRAGY WASOR W TNGKI, WTHA
REWE W,NIINNGHE TLE WHO GSET
NDEREP AREE DPEND A ITESEC BOM
U
DE HCHAR A TROITDMHE T.RU TTH
EER
THEROMSE' SER OETHNSEA RO
N
IT MILYARULTU I IADEST'
ORDHA TADON CTRHETIC TS. BOS
YOEV NERAN WT TOHO SFFOU YR
DEMMCOANR AND YOUEV NERAN WT T
O
RCUNDE C OUTRICTRONAD TTHE
COINDEANR-.HI-CEF
SO'R YFOUEN AE GRALER O AAR W
DEMMCOAN ARND YOUTA SAYRT SGIN
THTHE REGSIN AOIOT N GNGEL W
L,
'STHATOT NHA WTHE TSI PREYNTDE B
ONE EISEPOD INHE TOO BK, IO G
THNHUG IOM SELET DAI ISHA TT
TH OWAE SER GNEEN WALHOAS W
TTADMIHAGIN TNG TTHI N ASREOT
GOL. WGEL
HIE NAMAS W GERENALAV DID
NAKIMCERKY PNICHEAS W T WAR
COUNDEANR USRDE B AHT T EHEND
HISDEC SONER TMND A THETA SRT
OF OMABA'SIR FSTM TERND A HE WAS
RE F TLYHESTIRER GENALO TAY S
THIN AREOT N WOI GNGL.EL
ALETH TSANIB ITI GETNGTR S
,
ANDHI TS'T ISNNG GOIN I THE
EEWE N MDEORSRO TOPND A
OR E
URRESOS.CE
HSOE FAS WNDOU HESONTBO AUT
TH.
HESETVEEL RIE ODCOMMD.
ETHE GED FSIR INHE TGPR SIN OF
20.
OM BHEEC F TESHEMESTIR A
CAN
WARMA COM SERNDENCEIN GALER
DOacSLA MTHARUR IOREAO T
GE
ED FTIR TN IHEID M OEDLF A
WA
WEERASO NOO GDXP EONNALATI
GI T FNORS.HI
EFETH DECSEEN S ATARERYHE T
BTIMEES GOBAT AEL HDRE PSS
COENCE SAI HDEAS W LVIEANG
I
W BMUTNHEED ASK W HEUS JT
ISAID JTUSUG THO WDE NEED A
CH,GEE WDE NEEEWD NNK THIG.
E
AS WRE P AEDSSINGAND AGA AIN
AWHY YREOUIN FIRGIM H?
OUHE W GN'LDTEIV AETON CCR
E
ONREASNUT B IUM DOC WTSENE
INOBTAED FHEOR T BKOOHE TRE ARE
ASOMEFFYRM O IERICS
TAANGHIS WNHO WKORIT WAF
H
MCKINANHAS I TRT STHOOR BLYEFE
F WHEASEEDIR HON CSSFEES AND
ISAIDID D TOOOO GD OF AOB J
TEINGRUHE T T OTHFOW H BAD
TH AGSRE ORVEER HE AEND HAS W
YINGHE.RI PCE
RS COFOU YEOUTE BETELR BVEIE
THTEAFR ATVE E ORYICFFERN I THE
DEEPENS DTTMAREN NAK TESFEOT O
ATTH.
EYTHNO KW IFHE TYAK SPE THE
OUTTRHY TRHEON CTADTRIC TIR
BA C ISTLDOUE LOSHE TIR JOB.
TH WEASO NL REANC ITIENVEO T
ES HBEONH WTITHE TMERINCA
HELEOP WNG TNHIE WSEROT N
GOL. WGEL
>> SREHE'SY MOANSHI TNGOU Y
IIDNHA TTES R TNSPOETHAUS JTSA
R
THPTOM OST QERUENSIO.
WONEHADOR T ITIL WLER NEVNK THI
IOFN THE SAYEAM WFT AERNGEA RDI
OOURYO B IKSROGRS.ES
YSALWAHR TTGHOUOUHE W TARHE
LIE'S I WAKRE MGIN PS.GRROES
WEOTRE N SINAYGE' WREIN W
.
REWE AG AK MINSSOGPRRE.
IKLTFE LS TEHIEA MSSNGNILE
UGLY T BTHRUSERUT WEHE TRE
MOHASNT T F YTOU LLEEKIOONG
BANT I T TTHAREHEAS W S
EM
ONSSEEGI TFANEBLINUS STALEAB
WREOGSSHIREHE TOUSNG CE HLDAVR
E
DIREIOCTN?DN ATE BETR
PR S>>O WREOGSS AAS TKIALNG
PO A ATNDLLHE T GSERENALIC MIM
OEACHHAERTH TTAY WEC B TSEAUYHE
HE O TDHE GERTH SUY IAYND A
THTEW N IAS W ACCEP WBLTAEAY
ESTO D WIBCRESTHA I GNNGOI OND A
A
PL PKEEOL FEEEIK LESHI TNG ARE
IINGOG TNHEHT RIGIR D.TIECON
IDEYTH D SAY WNING EVE ORYENC
N
AHI WLEUT BGR PROSESAS W
TEFIDENI W TLYHEHEDOR TY LOV
TH AOS MTNDO ALSIK L TEHE
TRAPHSENGURHE TR.OR CNE
WEWE
URE'R THENGNI TROR CNEOW N,
GHRIT?
HOSO TE WSEERWO T OFHE TMO COMN
S.RAPHSE
THE WEER IIM TESTEL FTE LIK
ERTHE WASGR PROSES IHI T
NK
RFSUPEYIAICLLLMUT B ATOS AN
ILURONSI DBAGIN OIR'SMA F
STE
RMHE WEN HT SEN THEUR S OGEF
0 0,1000OOTRPS TFGO AANNIHAST
IKOKLO LY TEHEOU WELD BAKING
SOESRO PGR ISNER TMS OFIN TAKG
EAA RKE WL,EANGNIHE TIB TAL,AN
NGILBUDIHEP U TNFG AHA
GO.MERNNT
LT BWEUIS TONF OOO SCHNDLS A
ICCLIN ASNDOS H ATAPILSNDDS ROA
INSTHAFGNI.
WENT SPE A TONF OEY MONVE OR
ANERTHE KE LDOO ODNHE TUR SCEFA
ROKELI P BESGRSUTNEND UERHAT
ECATWH BE CAR IN THE
DO
SMECUNT OBTNEDOR F THE
WBOOKEOREHE PIDEPL D HTN'EAV
AN
TH FYAIHI TSAS WOI GONG T
,STHE TYW KNEHE T WREEERE SOM
FULENAMTA ILA FWS TNHE
HE
GYRASTTE
NEERMB OHEAS W THO WLESEUR PPO
BAOF OUR'SMA SAT SGETRASYEG WO T
DBUILP TNFG AHAER GOV
ET
HASO T TTHEFG A PNHAPLEOE
PAULAR INAL RURRE AAS
DWOUL WID SEHEHIT T GERNMT
TOVERHEANAL TIB,HA TTHE TY
WOHT FDIGSTGA AIN THEAL TANIB
TO TTEROCT OIRHEWNOV GT.NMEREN
U
INHEIE FLDEO PEPLAI SDHE T
GGHAFANENEROVNM C WTASARLELY
COHAT,UP THA ATFG N HNSADO
FA
TH ITINOAIRHE LNDE LEA.
IDEYTH DAVTN' HH MEUCAI F ITHN
RTHEIWN ORM AY TND AY
PALYULICAR TAT HEDHA AHEFG
NPO
ECCELI BHESEAU T SYAWM THE A
SIETHVEND AHA SDOKEWNTSRT AIS
.
YOUHIEE S T ISNIF DREFENT
IN
WSRVTEIEHE WRE WHITHA AFGNS
WH
HEEER TE WYER,SK AEDHY W ARE
U SING TIT WHHEANAL TIBR O
REYWH AOU YOT N SINPOUPRTGHE T
GO
NTRNVEME AIT WHS TLLHIOR WK
RI AEMERENSCA ANG DOI
RIETH TLDLBA EOUSER WLDAY S
WE
WOMLCE'T DEONIK LEHE T
BATALI W BNUTLL REEAY'T DONIK LE
GTHEENEROVNM W ATNDRE WTING
O
HOEE S WS, WINE W TNKHIHE T
TANBA IS AYUACTLLS ASAD B A
REEYTH A AHE TREE MREOR STPO
T
HJOINN TISHA THENMOV GER.T ENIS
IFAT SOUCR T SHEFAURCE IT
MEBECA TLE CARLLSEHE A OIOUSNS
F
REPROGE WSSER TOI GNGO VISH.
NE>> O IHI TNG
E L IOVO TR HEAU
OUTHNTSGH OHI TSCE PER OIOPTNSF
ETHNFG AHAITEC SURCE FYORS.
UGTHROHEUTHO T YOO BKHAOU SLL
OF
SCIFIALGAK MINOSITE
TSEMATEN TBO AUTBE NHEUM ARSND
KIETH SNDSLL ARAHE T T TININGHE
GHAFAN SY.URECIT
EMSTATTTSEN ADDSITHHO TSE
TH
YATOULS AOHO SW, WNHEOU Y
WSHOWOUTHA Y AREEA RYLLNK THI
ITOUABT .
INNOW HE T C ORSOUEHIS
WI WAWDRALADVEE' HHE TIDEN
AD
RANIMISTFTONTI OENXP EGSSREIN
O
B ORTF SWEETENEPRURISND A
AIDISD T FNORHA AHEFGECN SITURY
FOT TESHAHEYUL SHO HDEAV
MUGFOHTEORFF ELYTIECVESTGA AIN
THAL TANIB.
THA ERVE RLLEAYOS PBLSIE,
N GIVEOUATWH Y SAWBO AUT
SCIFIALO TSSMP IREFNSIO O HOW
H
RISEE CUCE FTYORE WSER
DE?PILONG
THNO T  WAYEEN WTUT ABO
ADIILNGHA ANFGY, ANRM I'T DON
H
TKIN IAS W PE.SIOSBL
THE WEERANO S MUC SYTR
RAL
LEPROB AMSNDWS FLA THA
GU TTEANEDHOSHI WJE PLERO
CTA
'T GNG TO WK.OR
INGACKHEO T TUE QIOSTNE
TABOUS,UB HRIIDHY W D WEHI TNK
OU CLDERE CATHI TRES P
YTTWE
MOENORHA AUSFGY ANRMND A
LIRAPAMIRYTA PICOLE,OR FCES A
NYMA AS50 300,0RMNI UFO
ED
ONPERSL?NE
AATTH'SYRE PTTIG B ARNIEM FRO
SCNDH,TC AE W DDIGESNET I TO
LO
E LOKIK.SHE T U.Y ARMHE WRE
TID
T HEYADERSHI VTR CYEN
NCHAIF OOM CNDMAND AHE TIR
CTEXPE USEDVANDCENSEA WPO
SYNDSEM AHI TSUR BTIUCEARA
CLO
ALSTGIICUP RESYPLTE SYSM.
BUI TLTSHIN ARM AYT THAK LOO
I
S OKEURSEEC BAUT' THAST WHAE W
HKNEW TO DO.
INVINT IERSEW O,LRAIS HRYTO
IETEINRVH WWSIT A.S U.YRM
CERS TRAERINS, GNGOIK BACOF
TO2000 25-7-20600HE TYER WE
WIININERG  AHE TIRENESSSSM
F
T2007ERYHE WHE WEIT INGRI
N
RTHEISMSS AEST O
HI TS.
STHEYEDAI WRE AIN TRAHEGIN T
ECANGH R AITRUS INDT WAST JUSAF
NDBEYOBIUR O AOTYLI TAK MES THI
RKWO.
NTHEYEDOTLL IER LITASYAC WHE T
ENROUSMO PHAEMBL TE MTOR
N
90 T O%FHEHA AFGRU RNEC
SIT
DNCOULD R'TEAWR OR E.IT
NYMAF OHE TMN'OU CLDT.OU CNT
TH
E W ONE. U.SFF OIAICL WHO
A
G YIDOU TOON A AHAFGNITEC RRU
ANANE H CL TEL YOU THE OAM NESF
HI BRO AERTHSISND SRSTE,UT B HE
CAT TLELOU Y HOWAN MYAS H.
ORFGERTH AECNHA R TITRUSYHE
CO'TDN CNTOU,HE TOUY CN'LDT
HELLTE TIR COROLS.
HOERE A W SPOSEOD T I
N I
N A
MA OERF AEW FEE W OKSF BICAS
TR
MNIAINGHEDOL TPL PSEEONTE IO
N
RM AY ON IURWN O?MA IGE
ITAS AOO F ESL'
ANRRD.
ABUTS YOUOI PNT O,UT INCUB PLI
.
IT MS.ILYARFF O KIAICLSTEP
WYISANGAKREHE MG PRO
ES,
ATHE AHAFGNSNG DREOI.RE GAT
ATHEYORRE MNDE AE MORAP C
LB
TALL THEE.IM
ILEYTH WEA DLEF TTHEANAL TIB.
NEEYTH KAU BWECIR TSEHEWN O
THATHE TFG A TN,HA CYHETLDOUN'
SH
TOO ST.AITRGH
WER NOTY VERRENS IPI TDO
HENDFE T OIRWN GENEROVNM
T.DE
CYOUEELDOU S THI CSINOMGOR F A
TNGLOEIM.
UYOFF OERMP EXAS O TSEHE
KI M OSFINLEISADTE SGTANTMES
CO
RONGMI FMLL AIN ADMIOTRISAT
A
N BVEEEEDNG EAGHIN I TS W.AR
OUTBU YLSE'R AHT ROIGN WHET I
CA
D TMEOINTOISRTG STISTS,IC
TODIINCARS OFGR PROS,ESHA TTHE T
DMAAM AATISINTRORNIO S
OTF
ITOOK A TTO NEWEV L.EL
DATID YOUEA MN BHA TT?WH
WOUSHLDCL CEONHAEUD T
T
NTESSE TLLIAYHEBA O TMAM WIT
H
WTHE OSTORRSENFFDEN I TERF O
IVDECEHEGIN TC?UB PLI
E
ERMEMBIE DS,ANTE WLRI HS,OWO D
YO
NK TUHIF ORE P ODESINTMABA'S
NLERO IHI TS W?AR
RE I>>N INADGHE T DSETSUMOCEN
ANVINT IERS W, DIDTAS W
TRSWOENHA IHO T
HTUG.
VEI CO P TRHENTAENGOOR F SEREVAL
YEM FSRO2001 20-
0- S
GSTHINER WENG GOI.L TKUT ABOOW H
YOHAKETA TITT W AHRA GIN OF
SA BUTT' IS AAR P OTF
ATRTFOUNER CEOVOVHE T GUN
NR
UROF OE. TIM
R YENOUHEDEA T DOCENUMTS
YOZEEA RLIHA TTVEHE TY' TENAK
ITO T A MHUCOR MEALYN CIC.EV LEL
ERTHEAS W ONEER INTEWVI,NSES LSO
DARLENEER INTEWVI AIT WH MBEEMR
ATEAMTHE THI WOUTE H T,SESHI
PESONAM NEAS WTEED RACM FDRO
OCETH D BENUMT K WUTEWNO
SO
WBOMEDYKE WHOOR ATHE
TSTDE ARE A P HYTTHIGEV L OELF
AL C TKAONSOUELND A HEAI S WDE
LANIMAPULD TEALETHE T MORCSRI F
H
TIDUE RA T OONF. WHEAR
HUSSLLNEI AHE TTA STSO THO S
W
REPROGE LSSIKUMBEFR OLSCH SOO
U
T,IL RDSOA PEDAV ORIO VNCLEE
LENG GLSOIRP U OOW D
N.HE
WAI SD HEADON TS OF
CSISATTIHA TTE W IONENNTTILYAL
LANIMAPUM TTEHEAKO T MT IK LOO
WLIKEAKREE' MROGIN PESGRS.
HEEDAI WO D TORSHI FWO
ONREASS.
HEERDAI VYLYLU BNTNE O ISO
MA
TKEHEEO PEPL INRG CHAEOO LK
GO
,ODND AD,EC SON TOAIAI MNT
NPU
UPICBL SORRTPO F THEAROE W
A
P KNEESRO TOPVE ORRE THEO S
TH
RE TATHE WOU BN'LDTES THI
ORORAM FHE TOP TRO TSO RURETN.
PATTH'STTREY RAD B,HTIG?
HA'SAT WPE HTAPNDNE ITN VIEAM
HIDAN TERS PNSO ISIT ADM
NGTI
THISAPPE NNOTUS JTN I
HE T
DFIELUT A THETE WHISE HOU AT
ATETH NNAIOL SYURECITEV LELLL A
THPYWA U TOHE TDERE PSI.NT
AVENWH DE GIDIVIAAT MERL TO THE
ENESPRID A FTORH,PE SECBA OMA
WOTL RDAT OEFF SICTITASTT TSHA
TH WNE KWEEREN INTLYONTIAL
IVCEDEPTE.
PATTH'S DTTREY SNIAMNGNTTETAME
E CTOOM SRO FMHOEOM WOR WK
FCTRELY P TORHENTSIREDEO T
USE TSND OERTHENOC DUM.TS
OUEYTH W W SLDAYLE CEOLLLCT A
SO S OSFICTITAST BSUTHE WN YOU
E
OAD H TND SPEHE TMWA ANY TYO
ALE MYSAKT IOO L LERE WE'
MA
NGKIESRO PGR
HINKBAMAND AET SOMEESIM H
TO
SOM OFHE TSTIG BGES FIB
AB W TTHE.AR
INEM DECRBE 2401HE TRE W A
NYRECEMO.ST A UIT M.ILYAR
ARADHEQURSTEN I KULAB, OND AMABA
T OU ATTE STANTMEGAY SINHI TS
WA THEAR W IN ASTHAFGNI
IS
NGCOMIURO T ONSES RPOLEIB
SINCCOLU,ON HEOU ANN TEDNCHEND E
OFBA CHEOMIST MONSI FOR U.S
TR
PSOO.
AAMOBA W HNDIS CARERMAOMND OF
MEE THTIALEN GER COH JNLPBAMEL
SAHE T U..SSRO TOPHE TILRE WL
BEEWUS THOFDAN OHE T SMYTA
INOUHE CUTRYNT BY' THENLRE O
Y
ETHERDVS A A
ORISS.
ATHEHAFGNS RRE ADYEAO T TEAK
CH
GE O THENS U AURECED TNDYHE
WIHEE B TNE OSHT FIG
GIN
NSAGAITALHE T TANIB.
..
ATD ANTHHE TYHO S PDNUL'T FHUSOR
H
TH TEMO  WE.
HEIN TASRYG TOUY BHE TM.
HEN,AI TEP DEC IONTI,ENT WT
ERDEEPND A D APEEER TEIM WTEN
.ON
>>OUENWH Y RSEAIDMA OBA'S
ICHEE,TEM R MDEINDE O OF ONEF
OMETH MTS TT IAD H
LECOMPISLYTE MRDSE OGO FORENTT
ATTH I -- SAWN IOU YROO BK A
D
SATTH I THATHA TTAS W TTN'HE
FI
T TE TTHA WELA DECHEDRE T
OFEND BA COMTRA OPEONTIS TTHA
MEE THSAT - - AAMETH SE TEIM
SI PATREUSNTDE B, WHAS YOU
OWKN,GAV HIN HIS MSIISON
SHMPCOLIEN MEDOMTBO AUTRA IQ,
MSE THRUASLDFE WN I KUL
DETHINARG  EENDF OOM CTBACL
OP
NSATERIO IN00 2
-AS W -T' IUSS J -T-INHI TNK
G
OUT --EA RNGDI WHYEA RNG
TH ROO BKHTIGOW N ISO S CZYRA
STOEE TSEHEER OTH MOMHETSEN W
E
INE'V KFD O DDLAECRET THAS THI
TH IS OR.VE
BUTOUONEN MTIEDTN VIE
AFLIEY H WNDEEAV AUE QIOSTNR
FROMEM A MRBEF OHE TNCUD AIEE,
MI
WAECHL,SK A DS,O YOUW VIE
TH
CLDEE BA INAB KUL SILIMARO
NESIGO97N I 15ND A'SHE TRE SO
TMUCHDOO IT WH UNGSIND A
NGSUMISIRIIS HTOLCAAL PARLSLE
REE NASONCSE TINHOWO TPI EDESOS?
>> ATTH A'SRE GATST QUEN.IO
WTHATTE QASUI A MENOMT.
OU AHENNOMESNC CPETBA OSTIRAON
RAIN I AQRER. OVE
TH M IISSAY OF3. 200
WTHATT JASUSHE TTA SRT OFHE T
R WAIN IQ,RAVEAS MSIUB PC
RESTILAONERLU BND RHA TT
LLY
CATOAC BK UN HT. HIM
OMBCOATONRAPETIAD HED END
CLUSCAE  TRLEAYERYHE WIN TERYG
E, MTOAKIV GE PPLEOEHI TS
ONESPRSI THA TTHE TWOAR WSM
WE AVE ORNDE WLD COUREEC DLA
ORVICT AYNDHE TNG THIBO AUT
'SFEMSLDHPE SEC IN PLATIARCUR
INAB KUL DTSUMOCENND AER WE AT
MIEARYTA HERUADQRTSN IUL KAB
ATY VHEERIM T AENDHE TYER WE
DOCSHKEHA TTSF RUMAIDEL SD TSHI
IWHD AT HSE TKIALNGUT ABO
CTHATBAOMT OONRAPETI ASRE O
E
EVWE N A GEROTGTHNYINO TTO SP
NGGHFITIND AY THEAM REDBLFLL A O
MEE THNA ORATIPES,ON OTIRAON
NDISTH AHA THAT TAST WTI SLL
GONDONG  ASF RUMD,ELGA A,IN
THIS I'TUS JTPI SN- -S THIS I
RULDFEYI LNGND AE H KW AND
TH
IT MEILYARNE KWHA TTHI TSAS W
TRNOT .UE
ETHESRE AWO T GATMP EXAS.LE
OMWE SIMETES - W-EAKEE'EO PPLS
ORRDWO FNDT I AS IT' HDAR TO
WROSPVEEYN HETH SHIOM SETNG
THMS SATEEFF O.
TH AERE TWOMO MAMTHHOAL FSESOD
3 2IN00 AND01 2 TTH4 ATHEAR W
WAVE ORHEN ITLYLE CARAS WTN'
INACT,OU YNO KW, BKACN I1 200
AFIDPRR ESSHT ENBUOU ANNEDNC
T STAROFIT MILYAR IN
AFN,ISANTAASE H WSK AED IN
FE CWSON ANCREE, YREOUEDOR WRI
WATE MHTIGET GKE SUCDNT IO A
LMIAGREEIKTN VIE.AM
HEAID, OH NO,E WEA LEDRNUR O
LEROSON FM V,TNIEAMEIL WL
NOET GDOG BGEOW D
N.
DOC MKEEP RTEORRST THA AEDSK
ARINE  WGO TO GETCK STUIK LE
VI
ANAETMNDNEOM SEOHTRO BUG UP
WOTHE RDIRUA QGMEND A HEOU WLD
FMADE OUNFEEO PPL ANDUT PHE TM
DO
.
FERUMSTE WLDRISO T GSERENAL
SAYI I'MLL REAYRI WOREDT THA
N' AWEREGGOT INO BBL AE TO
TGET OOPROS OUTFFG AANNIHAST
UN C WSSEPEOM U WHLA A PON T
ST TIZILEHENT COURY ANDED END
THO MEEMIT WHNE O WD,OREL HP
EWITHTILAXCMAONNT POI.
HEREMI DISINSSG ANYOM CRISO
TOTN VIE BAMUTN IRI PTEVA,
'STHATXACT WHAY TTHERE A
WOOUD IEABT.
OM SE WSAY FASARFOT-RWOS ADLM
T
EA20 YHA,RS THAST' WAPT HNEPED
WI
HETH T BENDM AATISINTRN.IO
JOWADEBIN DASS KEN IUL JY AND
ASHE WED ASK,OU CLDHE T BREE A
NESIGOTOM MENN IHA AFG,STNIAN
INMEANEWHG EROU Y'DAV HE
UAEVACFFONTI OOOHE T RFHEF O T
MBS.U. E ASYASNDOPEL HICRS AND
WADEBIN SER VY DIVMIISSSE, O
MAO N W,AYHA TTAN C NEREV
ENHAPP'STH, ATOT NOI GNG THE
ENHAPPT' T,HA WNOS TT'HASOI GNG
ON,F OE,OU CRS WL,EL AEW F WKS
THTELAR GSINCT ALLUAYK LOO WSEOR
THANIC HELTEOPRFF O THEOOF.
UYOAD HSMA IGEF OIR AOR FCE
SPTRANLATOR PH WNEIT THE
SGHAFANNI RUNOWNG DNHE TUN RYWA
NGTRYIO T CLINGO T
IT.
I MHEN,EA TGE IMA W TEERERIERBL
D ANWEED ENDP UATVA ECUG,
INHELP TGO EECUVAAT ADR HUNED
SATHOUPL PNDEOT JEUS A FEW
WE Y SS,O,OU KW,NO M IN,EAES Y
ERTHARE EAL PARLSLE TOIG SEON
ANAMIE VTN.
Y AIRTNLARERTHE EFE DIFNCREES
DANDNTFEIFRETSSP AECTF O I BUT
ERE THOVERLAL PPTIO A TNDHE
AVWEY  H TEOLE FE, RLLEAY,
THILWHE ENE E,MY MNIEANGHE T
N LITABAIS SEENGKIR, OVE IEA MN,
AROSTHE NGSTE RO PLSALARLEND A
EE OSARSMA IGEHA TTRE AAR HD
TO OETUT OFOU YR
EA HD.
T W IANSKO T AS U A CPLOUE
MOIOUE QSTOR BNSEFE I- - IO G
TO -- I'MOOKINGT AER VYD GOO
ONESQUTI TFRS OMIE AHEUD AENCND
ISONE  MHO, W-HUC - IOP HS TEHI
ISOOOT T PSIARNG B M HUTOWHUC
YDOOUHI TNK.S U O.LSICFFIA
JULTRYLATUS FT OUT T LIE T
BLPUUT AICBO WARS,ER VSU YOU
OW
KNKITH, E F OTI PUTNG GDOO
FA OCENNG THIS O THE
ELLFSE-DION AT SETOMES
HA WS ENIN ATIARME TTHE
HIVET ESLE.LS
TEL WL, AT'HAS GTHNOERDOO
ONESQUTI
AY IEN S L,IEON I D'T SAY THAT
Y.GHLITL
THNGAS WHIOSNTO PE WTERNYF I A
IZITCRIC B FEDOROONGEI T
TTASINTOHASE U TTOR WRE WDHE
GIYOU PL PVEEO TEHEITEN BEFF O
DTHENDBTOU AE W'T DONNO KW
AT'SHEN I TD MIRINHE WNY THE
SAINMESOTH J WG,EOITUS PNTUT OY
H
S IATT' A FSETA SMETENT OR
DINTCORAYEDCT BDE EVIENCND A
IKGSIN L.THE IS
INHIEAESRCS TNGHIOO BK,IN AGA,
RECOI VE TDHEGOEN PTA M FNORYAN
E
SARND A'V IERE CORNTONSPDE'M I
DAE USTON SYPIND AEEO PPLIV GE
PPY LK.
I GHAET TT.
E'ERS CLYTAERIN L AOT OFA, L
EAMISLTANGDI SS.METENT
OUENWH YOO LKT A THEUA ACTL
DOCUNTSND A THEOR CONLARETI IN
I
OMENHA W STYEBOMODAI SDN
NDICBL A THA WTYHE CARLELY
AKNEWTITHT E  T WMEASRERU O
E,FALSN, M IEAANOU Y C'T DO
BHIYTNGCL CUTONEUDREHE TY'
RI
SF RKEUMDELAY SGINOR MAJ
.2003BTIPE ORARESON AR OVEN I
IN,EARE THE'S NOBT DOUE HNE KW
H
WAST TTERU AHE TIM TE.
HYOUESEAV TMOTINYY BEEO PPLHO W
SE UND HIMHO WUS JTAI SD
TH
ISLA FOUT-TN' WAST ARU TEND
IKSTJU LMA OEBAAY S IGINAST W
THFDEN OHE TBA COMT M,SIISON
KNET TWHATAS WN' TE.RU
AND  HHEADHO AUTZERID THERO TSOP
FIEE KP TIGHNGN IBA COMT.
SE TSOHO AREWO TIG B - B
LIHT R,IG,RE THE N'SOAY W
AR
T.NDOU I
SEW HOEL YAN COUIBES DCRET. I
ATE SHEAMIM TE,'R YOUE RHTIG.
ETHER WLS AOAS A LOT OF,OU Y
IOWKN,ONLANFTI OFEC EXPS,TITAON
AOT L OFEO PEPLPI SINNNGHI TS,
HAOF WOIST' GNG ON, YOUW, KNOIO
TH
SN DATOE'TUI Q CSSROHE T
NELIDDUT B AT I A ULLPT' IS NOT
ODA GOEC R ODORFDYNY ABOEL TNGLI
H.TRE UT
MAS IEDTIENON THENE OALEN GER
WHHELDTO TRU TTHOT GIR FEDND A
LETHE ONSS FMHA TTAS WOU Y
AMEREOANIC PEPLND A, YOUW, KNO
OLTHE  CÉCHLIE TTHS IHE T
ASTRS CLTUAY OFAR WO SRE THE'S
TO HNGIS ORYFHI TS A BUTT
E
TSAMEEIMHE WN ISOU YRTAMP IORNT
O
ORNTME F.S U.RSEA LDEO TE B
HOSTH WIT THE PLIUBCHE WN
'SOPPELE AIV LESTH OREN E LEIN
AN AWERETTOM CMIROGIN TNDSOP A
T A LOEY MOFONO TON CICFLTF HAL
ARWAY NDOUOR W.LD
ABT.TOU IE T BTA SRTONNGEI HTES
D >>ANEEE THSPS TCHHIK, WEE
PR BENIDTENIDTATED
AFGHNISANTAS I AVE OR,THE T SAM
E METI HEIDSA W WLILAI MAINTN
FINSAGT AIORTET RRNMIS I
AFNISANTAEND A W JTUSON'T
OEDNE TIG FHT ADRO GUNAR W TO DO
T
END A WAN CETR SIK FMROR, AFA
ATHWIN RIMECA OOTBOS TNHE
NDGROUY V,ERFEW F IEE ND.DE
TH TSEE EMOMBEO  SEEIG WGL
ROOM,HE TREOU YW, KNOND AAS BED
YHA WT'VEEE SNR OVEHE T
WOSTPA TEC DES,HA WTO D YOU
INIMAGUR FEUTE U..S MYITILAR
ONACTIFGN I AANNIHAST IFNY A
COLOD OK LE?IK
>>ELL,SHA TT'ERNO ATHEHR PAS
THEEO PPLDHO SULCH WATUT O
FO OOO BTS TNHEUN GROD.
'STHATHIOM SETT TNGHAMA OBA SDAI
LAOTND A PPLEOEAY MOR FVEGI
THUT BHE WN HET SEN TOPROS
AIHE SDAR PRLCUTILAY WHE TRELIL
B NBEONTSOO OHE T GUNROD, W
EAR
PUNOE T  UINTTGRO..S GNSUP O
TH
NDGRE OUN IYR SIAND A,F O
, URCOSEIDEYTH DND AOR REPRSTE
WO WSAD Y, DTHAO YOUN MEAO N
OTSEN  OTHUN GROD.
AVWE HTU PEICSRE OFALIT LERLY
OTS  THE GUNROD,F O
ANERAMIC
LD WEYOUHISE U T K TSODINF, O
G
N,AIIV GEPL PEOES THI
NGEASLDI TMA IGET W D'TON
KNYOU ,OW IO DHI TNKHA TTID BEN
-
I TE HIMT AIS HOR WDT THA
T IISSSHIOM CETPLERO T
N
L DRAWOM AHANINDANST A
THOSE' NFG ANHAY ARMR O
RNME TODV AEISRENY AMO.
HASO TROT LES I GE.ON
SERTHE'URO N PSEPOF O HINAVG
THE.
REWE AOT NNG GOIO TE BNGOR WKI
HALOND A GVEIT WHHE TALIB
INT THA SEAMAY W BUTOE DS TTHA
ANMET THAHE T CIA'T WONEN ST
IVEROPAT IESN?
TDOI UBT. I
THACIIL WLRY T TOD FINAY W TO
REVEHA P ANCSEENDRO PXYCE FORS
S RHPEAPHEDAN TAR ISOI GNG TO
INNTUEN I AREIF DFENT W.
'SITUS JTOT NVE OARILRMITY
COLICT YUT B,OUNO KW, C ITLDOU
ORBE MEIK LE,OU YNO K IW,NHE T
ARANGH W WNHEHE TTSOV SIEERE
HEIN TE,RE WE WERNV IVEOLDN I
E WATARNVEUG THOHE WTID DN'
CHTEY CANILLOOVEHA BTSN OHE T
GR W BNDUT AWEE REIG BLA PRYEOU
W TINHEARET BENWE THETSOV SIE
ANDHE THA AFGES RETAISNCT A
TH.OI PNT
I' NAYOT SHAGIN T WST'T'HAS
TINGOG HAPN NOWUT B I J'MTUS
NGSAYIREYO, U'IG R,HT'SHE TRE A
OFLOT IGGLOO RMRE THE FORHE T
AFGHNISANTAOR F CTENTOUERMORRRIS
P
NSATERIO
TH>> REE ERWEASUI STC M OESFEYON
TONHEDRO GUNAC BKNHE T
.80's
SOEW FUE QIOSTNSM FRO --RO FM
H
--E HE TNCUD AIEE.
ONE T'SEE SAB GELRIS, ASK YOU
OWKNG,CR, AINK THAOU YOR F
REG.RTPOIN
E E NCTHTLLPUOURO FM
ISGHAFANHENTA T'SREEE BNOM SE
CO
MILIONRYTA CRSACTRTOAV HE.
TENEBEFIDM FRO THE PEDLORONG
WA
R.
YODID U CEOMSCR AOS THIOP TIC
HEIN TRS COUE OFOUR RNGOREPTI,
IFT WOHAID DT IK LOOIK LE?
LLE THROF OON CRSACTRTON IAR W
ALS AO GATRE WAY TOUD FGE
TS OTONHE GUND, SO WTHAID D
O
-U -HA WTID D YOUE MAK TF OTHA
THEOURS OEF YROUEP R,TIORNG
WH FHEETRS TORHI BKOORR YOU
OVL RERTGINN OHE TLO GLBA
OWARORTEN RR?
>>LLWE, EXALYCT.
TOWAA Y E B SALPTKEICF OHA WST'
GONGIN O BUTINER CTALY MYITILAR
RACONT YORCTS,W, KOUNO THE
EDEARN A LOTF O MEYONGHHR TOUTOU
ARETH WIN, AC FT,US J ATUTBO
HADINNY A K ODFNCRE PSEERE THE.
THONIRY IS WE SPE SNTOUCH
NEMOYN OSEEF DENON C AACTRTSND
RETWHHEST  IWAITMM AUNRNIO O
RWATE FR ODOOR,OU Y K WW,NOE
TOHAD EN SDHI TSNO E AOURMSUNMOT
OFUP SIEPLSFW HALUN AAYRO TDHE
DWORLHIO T TSNT COURY IN
GHANTAN  TDAN IEONKHI PEPL
MEMESOTI'T DSONLI REAT WZEHA A
LO CICSTALGELLHAENEAND A FT
WTHAT BASUT AE WOLSPE SNT
EN AMOORUS OUNMOTSFON MEYOI DNG
TH AATNDEO P WE,PLTHHEERHE TY
U.ARE  DS.ENEFSE CTRACRS,
REFOEFNIG DSEENON CRSACTRTO,
ANAFGHN  ES,VEETHANAL TIB T,YHE
BEALL DFINETERO FMHIS.
I NE,AN ONG THIHA TTE WOU WLD
HEINE  TER INTEWVISUS JT HOW
MMUCHASEYON W- - ANDIN DUR
OB
A'AMSER TMIN DURG TURHE SGE
TAMIE LIRYDU CONEDCT AEV RWIE
FLL A OHE TEN DEFACON CTR.TS
PHA TTHENTOI TERRE WE MOR
10ANTH $ONIL BLIR Y AEAEI BNG
SPFGINT  AANNIHASTND AHE TY
DENCCOLUTHD ATS MHUC AS0% 4F O
ETHEY MON WEI BNGNEIF SFE ODFF
ANEND WT TOIL MARITYEM MRSBE OR
YBEVERSY ODWAITEN BEF FGINMRO
TISTH,D GHEOO GSUYND AHE T BAD
GU
TA CATEREDLYIN RNYESUC A
NTINCEOEIV THEND E T FG,HTIGIN
NOST QUEN.IO
T T>>HATSGEER PCTFELYO T A
, TIESON TULWODNGHIS HEAV
DIDEEND TLERFFEN HYADE W
ER CATICEDIORUORPT INN
AFN?ISANTA
ONWAYHIO T TUT ANKBOHA TT,AD H
OTWE NVAGG ARA IDTE ATSEL WL?
>> LL, KTHI INSHA TT'
AYE
ETHR ET BTEOYWA T LKOOT AT I AND
E ONATSTETMEP DARTENFF OIAICL
ETBARNENRET UBAI SD,'SHE TRENE O
ARCENESSYNG ITDIREENOR F
ONUPRRTIHAND A T MST' AEYON
D
WE TRE AHENE OS WHITLL THE
YMONEECND A BSEAU A WERE
ADIOONGSTHAFGNIH WANITORE
MON TYHA ITAN CBLOS PSIY
SOAB WHEER I WTASEN DEFSE
RACONTRSCT OIO NATDIBUN-ILNG
RAPROG OMSRITUM HANIAN, AID
ITINEVLEAB AOT L OFON MNDEY EED
PE IUPN LEOP'SKE POCTSHA TT
LDSHOUAVTN' HTE GEOTN IT.
ON H OHENEHEDAN TDNI UTE
ST WESASRIEC LTUNGHE T AFGN
O
NTRNVEME,OU YEE ND TOTA SMP
OU
UPCOT RRONTIND A WE WLDOU
TRESJUN DGND ASOU CRTO DLEA
TWITHS.HI
ON TER OHETH WAN HD,ARE EGAK MIN
APIT HECNPE BESEAU WRE SENNGDI
YOOWKN, T OREHE'SNEPI E IDESON
A
AROU6  2ND00ASATTH WEN ST BY
U.S. ADOASMBSA IRNNIFG AHAANST
THEIM TEE NAMON RNEW NMAND A
TAUT AEDBOTI MEEH WNGIT THE
AFGH PRE IDESINTCH WNHI THE
ORSSBAADAT BERGINBO A ALL
ONUPRRTIND A SGLING B,THROER
AFGHNISANTAGAY SINEEOU Y ND TO
REIMVEMO H,E' HSPTOR CRUO THE T
CONND A I TAR PTSHI ISIS H
OTBRUTRHE BIS H CK,EBOMACOU Y
ARTHE ES GUYIN GIVGLL A THE
MO
DY NEAN OE' HS TNHEIA C
PALOLND A THE DENEFSE AF,ND O
COHA,SE W CTAN YAY S TO
ONATTH, NEHE T OD HANE W
LEHEEDUR TFG ANSHA TOLE CAN
UINTHGS W APNDWEE RE
ONRESP FBLSIE A L OFHO TSE
PRMSLE.
TDAN ITNKHI IAS W TOOCUIF DFILT
DI ETORAORTECA CNPTRUIOSEEC BAU
OFE RUROLN IT I ANDHE TFG ANHA
TSAW ASHIS A WAYNDTID DN'
KNONHE T M G WEYASONGOI TO G
AWHEND A TY WEER ALL TRYOGIN T
GE ACE PIEF O ITSEEC BAUOU Y
DO
NOTN' K T HWOW WHEARSOI GNG
URTO T
OUN T.
INI THL ITK 'LY VBEERAR HD BUT
STE THMO DTIASEVTAT PNGARF O THE
UPCORRS ONTI IAT I RLLEAY
TMADEHEHA AFGNPL PEOOSE LE
FAHEINH  TIR OWNER GOVENNMT
SAAND W A BCH OFESHI TEV
INLOOKFOOUG T IR TRHEWN O
REINTEST ANDNFG AHAID SED
IH
TTHEIBANR OVEHE TIR OWN
MEVEGORN.NT
S ERTHE' W WNOAYE WEER TOI GNGO
I
THE R IT TFHAAS WOI GNGO T
.PPHAEN
TI G>>ETK BNGACHIO T TSIO MOTN
OF PSGRROEST THA WVEE' DCUSS
D
AEIT LTLIT B.
PELE PNTOIO TMP IVEROMENT
GIS INNIFG AHASANST A
SSOGPRRE,S IVAHA TT D?LI
H, Y>>EA THEUE Q IIOSTNS WTHA
SSOGPRREOIS I GONG T BE
SUE NAAIBL A NOROTND RIG NOW
H
V'SAT A OYERNPEUE QIOSTN AND
REAL CONRNCE.
ANHI TSAS W- -UT BHI TISS
TALRELYST QHEUEN BAUSE TSHI
OTSGE THE TNT POI W OFTHAER WE
WE
OL TD TOOM ACC IISPLHN
TAANGHIS
WEENTARO T W 2 INT100 I
WA
OTOS  GFT AERL-QAA AND
TSNWA'TORO IMPVEHE TES LIV OF
WO
THATINER CTA WLYASHE TEL NOB
,GOAL IHA TT W'TSNHY WEEN W TTO
WAR.
ECATTH BRTE AMPA OFHE TONIS MSI
AST WE.ER
THSHBUISDM AINNATTRIO
LYTFGHUL WAI SDEDHO SULCK STI
UP- -E W SULHOD TRY AND IROMPVE
E WHILWE AREHE TRE BUTHI TS
CAME UIX MEDH WPITHE T
ORURALIN PFSEPO O THEAR W AND
TINKHI A LOTF OIM TES THE
ANERAMIC YS,OUNO KW, WD TEN TO
ECPROJ O OTURWNAL VSUE IN
ROTANHERYOU CNTOND A THA WT
CGRDEEE YANOUYEA RLLO DHA TT
HOD PELL IT'E TAK,RO GUP
I
OWT N'KN.
HE URBANRE AASF O
ISGHAFANNTAE LIKUL KAB,OU Y
, KNOW IERTHE -S- THEOT LF O
DN MEAN HIR GLS CAS AEOMON LG
Y.WA
E EYTH'RO LEAB TGOO T SOOCHL.
ANEYTH CAK TOBE JSND A INTORMPTA
ONSIPOTI T ISNER GHEOVENNMT AND
N'I DOT WTANO TIN M TIZIMETHA
NTBU I RALURRE A, ASIHI TNK WE
ARVE OINEARRCH AGIT BOR F
POSI O ONGURWNUE VALSN OHA WT
AFERSAN WE RDY FORND AT THA
HA BTOEHIOM SETT TNGHAOM CE
ENOMFR MN IAR PT A SS TOHI IS
G THMEINEATTH W WSTLEIT WH
BU,GA AINEV NER RLLEAY STED
T.OU
WWHATE ERWEGOP HIN TO
AC
SHMPCOLIND WT W OASUR
PU
FOSRPENG BOREIHE TRE AND
WHRE TEHEROAS W P MESGRSEADN I
NYMA R,AREGDSHE TLE WHOST QUENIO
O
T  TWHAT LWEOSHE TAR W, WT'S
GINO TN?AP HPE
AK S>>PEFGIN OSHA WT' GNGOI TO
PPENSLE, T'ET G AEIT LTL BIT
T WTOHAAS H JTUSAP H
NEP.
T IDESEN HDEBINAS EEDREXPSSN I
NTRECEAY DS TT,HAK, LOOAST I W
SSIMPOOLEIB TET GUT OIT WUTHO
SOE EG DREOF COSHA.
THLWAS W A GSAYO NGOI TBE THE
NDSECA A- - ANDIN KARAS ASK
F
THISS IE, TRU WLDOU TREHEE HAV
ABEENTE BNYET WRAY TEN BHEID
NIADMIONRASTTI HOU CLDAV
DEAVOI TDHEHA CICOTXI ETRO FM
ISGHAFANN?TA
NK T IHI CHE TYAVLDOU HE
PL LDNE AOTR,ET BTE NO
ONESQUTI
AR CEYLEE WLYER CGHAUTFF O
GUD BYOW H QCKUILY TIB THEALAN
LES WAABO TAK T OERVEIT CAPSAL
RCD ANMAHT RHIGNT IOAB KUL
THEYLYLE CAR NER WEOTDY REA FOR
TH
INTHKEL INTEGELINC ASSTSSMESEN
TSHOWHETHA TID BEN
STMIADNI TTIRAON TUGHOHTADYHE H
LEA ASTEW FSON MTHF I NOT
,NGLOERHA TTHE THA AFGN
GONTRNVEMEND ARM AYOU CLD HDOL
D T OUANEREYTH W'TENPA PREDRE
FONDISTH A TYUL SHODE HAV
HA
TI CDONESENNGCI INLA P THA
MU.E S.YITILARLA PNS FOR
EV.HIYTNG
P TATHENTAENGO'SHE TRENS PLAN O
THE FHE SLFORAD INVGINANAD
EBONODYRVEXP E TTSECO USEHE TM
BU THE'S PNSLA IND AM A
RISURPHADSE T WTEN' DID HTEAV
BENS PERLA IN FLA PCEOR A
ENSUDDATVA ECUFNIO IE WEE NDDE
IT
ARND A PRLCUTILA TYHELA PNS
WAS- WASIEEF DIC INTNIN TRY
GO
SSRO PCE INTIGMMRA FIS VAS
ANAFGH H WSHOAD HPEELD T
EDITTA SS,TENT IERPRERETS ORUN
CILVI SSVAERNTR O OERTHOLES
T. TKEHA
TH.S U.W KNEHI TET GACNGTI BK
TOBA OMAISDM AINNATTRIOHA TT
E'THERUG AS HAGE BK LOC OIS VAS
H
N' HATADBET ENRO PSSCEED AN
CO
BDNUL'TDONEUI QLYCK.
TH ADEBINTRINDMISIOATN HAD
DEMAVEMP IRONTMES T ONTHACE SIN
NHEGI MARESNSIN SCEAN JRYUA
BU
WTHT ATET SASOMHANGHI TT WE
LDSHOU BAV HETEETREEOR FES ANND
ERBETTRERE PPADOR F.
WE TADOO DCU EVA TIOATNSETHA W
WEUS JT -- WHE TRE NASO RLLEAY
A
ROTOY  PLLSSCE AHEF O T
PLIC, IOATNSE WWEERUL PNGLI
OOPPELEUTIL WLY NILND A VYER
C.AOCHTI
SOHES,YE T CYLDOUE HAVE DON
T ERTT AMEE THSA YIM TE,OU
, KNOWSERTHE' AEV NERY ENYASAY W
NGLOSI WHE T TARTHAOU YE'R
Y  E'SASRT STOTANE OUT B A LOT
HA E TEROND ITND A YOU LK AT
STE THLA 7,EA YRS OMABAND A
P TRUMDANID BEN ALLRI T TEDO END
THEAR W.
OBISPRA OM W HEDEYLDOU B THE
OENDON SFECM TDERHEND A T
IEWORRRE TDHE BOU WLDE A W
SELLCOAPF OHE T AHAFGN
GONTRNVEMEOND A SE H KTEPOP TROS
TOVERREHE.
TSAMENGITH,RU TMPE H
EDOMPRISNDO T EAR WND A GSERENAL
DVIADSE HF,IM I YOUULLUT O NOW
COLLSEAP.HA GTNMERENIL WL
NEYOU  TEDOEE KPOP TROSRE THE
TEVENHEUGHOH DIC KKE THEAN C
DO
R TWNODOAO TEN BIDO TEAL
WI IT.
DEBI DMAN DENISECIO E TOND T
IT DN'IDTAV H B TEOEHA TT
TICHAO
>>TIMEOR F A CPLOUEOR ME
I'M TOINGOG OC F IUSNN OWO T
THAV HE TOO DH WIT --H WIT
NAJOURMISMLI, ENOCR S ASEND
SECRMAO E.NS
LL TE THEIC MROEN SSE
RSFIT.
NDLIA AOS,SK D YE HOUAV
CHSEREARHASER TK WTORIT WH YOU
OR
HIAS W TS AOLOTIPE ORA.ON
DIORUYO WNK OTH OER
ASGNVENT ORHE T CRSOUEN O
NRKWO I AHANIAN?
INO , TID DN'OR W OKNTH OER
ASS.MEGNNT
THYAS W MTIUL FL-ME JN WOBHE
WEUBEER PGSHLIIN SHE TIEERSN I
OSETH PT ANDHE TN FORN I02 2
FA SDO RN I02 2 T1,SSHI ILL A0AN
IDI DORAS W WNK OHE TOO BK.
MYDII D  OWNEA RESORHRC F ITUT B
ITA CERADLYIN HRM ENOSOUTMO AUN
SSOF AETAISNCN IHE TSR NEWMOON O
THRIE OSENAGIL NESRI I TMSERF O
OREDITT- FS,ACRSECCHKEE P,AG
DE WERGNS,TE PEOSD ALL OF
OCEES DENUMTS ONHE TER INTTNE
DED ANMA TMHE E TYASORC SEAOH S
E
OULEOP C SLDEE TM.HE
ESO WHIAD H TSUG HEFF ETOR ON
ETH,TA SFFGRHO PTO,HEAPRS
PHOGDERAS,ERNEES DIG S,RSOI
MAPL PNYEOEDWOE RKITH
HI.
I SHE TOL SE RROREPTEN OHI TS.
HEIN T IOO BK,AS WHE TUT ARHO
ADTBU HME TRE HOUNDSPEL INHE T
NENOMRO IER TMSF OTI EDI ANGND
TAESPRENNDONTI A DIDAVE A
FAERHE-CCKTIUL FL- WMEHO
WO
NEDRK OCHAC FT- FKIECNGHE
OKBO TND ASHISN IET S'TOMNGHI
TH
UATALSULYEPORRERSTE A
ONRESP FBLSIEOR HISR OER H
FACTHECKORGIN FEW NSESTO SRI,
S TSOHIS I A WHINGNTOT POS
NDOKBO AT INE JOIDHE T TALTSEN
SSACROEEO PPLF OEW NOOSRM, NO
ONESQUTI
>>DHO SUL OOI PNT AUTS A
OWFELLOS PTERTA SFF TTHAN
TSOJPRECIK LEHE TSES IT' NOT
UN TMMCOONO, SEE YOUNO KW,
BYLID S NEANFEON OHIHE T TSNG
TH
S WATASOMA ANGZIN WHEHE T
PAE CRSAM OUTS AIR FSTJE PRO
T
ASIT WHA TT W ITAS B CIGRA.
TEAU[LGHR]
>>T WASN AUO ARDUS ANDTO SRY
BWORK'R YUTOUIGE R,HTT' IS A
THBIG G.
THETH OST QERUE ONIOFALOU JRNMIS
ITOFOR ME  A MROACIOUE QSTN
COFRS OM- -ET L MECR SOLL DNOW
TOT. I
,BERORTTOB RERSK AS, DID THE
SPRESAI FL IN ITSL ROLOL REO T
IN TRMHEME ACARINLI PUBCBO AUT
E FAURESHA TTOU YE'R
RENOINRTG
W?
IYE S, THI TNKHE PSSREAN C
YSALWAO D ARET BTEOB J.
DON'T WTANO TEE SMSIEF DENVE
IBUT  MHI TNKYANTEEP RORRSID D
VE JOO GD OOBFOV C TINERGHE
WAHA AINFG ASTNIANANND MYF
SUE ESISE WESEROR REPD,TEER WE
MAUBLIC AUTBOPTOR CRUNDNIO A
GHAFN,ISANTA -BO AUTUT A-BO THE
R
LEOBMS T ANDGINRAIN THE AHAFGN
MYARND AEOL PIC F ACEORND
CELONLAIY TS OFRI STOES
TIQUES WINONGTHHEERHI TS
WI WAWDRALNG GASOIO TO GEL WL
NEAND IOTIGOATNSIT W THHE
TADN BAANUESTNIIONG
TISKEPOVLCA CAGEREHR TGHOU THE
S.AR
DO EOFUGNOH T I ORAY MBE DN'
CEYAIRTNLTSUT OLETID DN'O ME
T,OF I'SHE TREO NIOUE QSTN IN
YCERENTRSEAIN SCE 2EN4 01WH
AOBAMNCNN AOUNED AND E T TOHE
CO
ISATMB M LONSI AOTF O
ERPORERTT  LSEF ABUKALND THE
SILETEVIWO NONETSRK IN
ICPARTAR GEN AH MSUC
NTATTEVENIO ORHE TRE AND
AFNISANTA OIN KDFAM BECHEE T
TERGFOOT F WNAROR A.HI WLE
IDSO D WEEE ND TOOV CER ITE MOR
Y,OSCLELUTBS AOLY.EL
K LWEOOHAT A WPE HTAPNDDNE A
TH
NE'ERSST QOUEENIO WLD COU
HA MON DEEORUT B ILS AOON D'T
TO NIMI TZEHEIS RKS AND
ESIFCRIC TTHAAN MYALOU JRNTSISSA
IMADENOI GNG TO ASTHAFGNI,AN
INSTAYRE TGHE.
THSHINONOS PT HAS HAD
AUBUREN  IBUKALVE ER SCEIN1 200
ANAVSO HETHER NERSPEWAPS.
SWIE RESVIERCE TIK LEHE
CIASSOREEDAT P ASSNDRSEU RTE
HAER COVEDNG THISIG DILTLENY
LDAN A OOTFPL PEO PEUT
ESSEEMLVEAT A RK RLISO TO D
.SO
'T DIONTOAN WT  MEIMINIZT THA
COUL WE ONVEHA DE ATE BETR
SB,JOE,UR AELOLBSUTY.
ITBU'T DONNOWHATE WLE FAI
.
VEE  WHA --OI'M I G TNGO SAKNE
INNE LTASUE QIOSTN.
I TRS SKUCRO FMHE TY VER
G NNGIINOTATTH BH
OU YR
RTREPONGIN IHE TOS PTND A
ANAFGHPATAISN RSPE AND THE BOO
YOOWKN, HASEN GISES ANDHA TT
E PUIMLSDE WISONHAULRF T TTHE
MIFFRYTA OIAICLS AND
DI OATOMICLSICFFIAOU WLD --
DWOULAN WT TO,OU YNO KW,ET G
DTHATNOWO TES ASSS WTHAHE TY
VEHA L.RNEAED
YO DATO NK TUHI WEAVE
D,ARLENE AHA WTHERE TES LNSSO
LE FNEARDMRO THEFGHANAR W?
D>> INO'TON KT TWHAE WEDEA LRN
.THEM
INK MBE WE L TRNEAEDETHA W
TDON'AN WT TO GETNT IOR OVE OUR
AHEADE TNDAKN O ESRMNOOU
KEREMANT COUESRIRS OVESEA TO
ULRTPAICOULYAR C WRINTES DE'T
UN VTARSNDYER WL.EL
I MHI TNKBEAYHE T'SREE SOM
TYMIHULIND ARD OER HEER I AND
TH
ERKIN C IINTALYNCUB PLI
N INOPIO IBONODYSLAMBINGO T
GOAD INVNOE AERTHNT COU ARYND
TRY A TRAFORMHE TTYOC SIE.
NK T IHI'SHE TRE ANIEC ROGONTISO
TH WATE OCHRRVEEA IEDN
AFNISANTAOR F A LGON TE.IM
THATAI SD,AMIE VTNAP HNEPEDND A
HTHO TUG WAY MBEEEDEA LRNUR O
E
FONSSSHEMRO T AREND WE
DI.'T
MED ANSOAY DHE TOI'SRE G B TNGOE
R OTANHEISCRISOM SHEEWREN I THE
WOAND DHE TDNI UTESTA STE
TONDTES EA RCT MILARILY IF
UIT'SHRERND TNDTEA AHE T
ITIESON AHOS WERE W GNGOIO T
T REACWD ANHOERE A W GNGOI TO
DE
H  WALITETHIT STIONHAT
OMKEMA C UEPHA TTAY M BEARIM SIL
ST BUINEOM OERRYOU CNTND A
PHEOTRTAR OF THEOR WLDND A I'M
TISKEPATL CATHE' WVEEDEA LRN OUR
E
ONSSS.
ONLEE SSED MAYE BHE TRE TO
NDADRE A S AND HR,EAUT BRE A
NG GEYOI TO SKIN IN, ISS GUE
TATTH'SST QHEUENDNIO ANL OY
TITEIL WL H WLLIT THAT.
IG C>>RA I,AN C'TGI IMANE AOR ME
OMLYME MORTEN FOU YROR WK TO
OCOMEUT T ANDSHI BK AND I
HOT  TPEHAL WITILEL HPS U
RET AN MAYBEVENEARN
F MESO OOSTHESO LESNS
TEL WL,OUNKHA Y,AR CS,LO
U K ANYOHERFO TRE GAT
USSI AND IEA RANYLL WT TO
KTHANENHE T CORRTE FNGOS HTI US,
T
'S A RLEARI PLEVIGE AND.ON HOR
ETHESERRE A TFICUE Q AIOSTNSND
SIT I EGIOUNCRA TNGHECUB PLI
PONSPSE DPLEOET WOANO TNO KW
T WATENRO W INGNFG AANNIHAST
AN
TANYHE W TTOR HEA IT
STIGHTHEND A TT WYANN A
PLEXN ATANIOT WOFHANEAP HPE IDN
ASETH L20T RS YEA ANDOW HHI TSNG
COROGOD  WNGNGEE SMILYO S
QUNDYKL AE HOP THEK BOOAS H
ANOSTHE ERSWSND AL WILIV GE
PE ALEH MUCTE BETR FLF OHY W
THGS WTEN.RO WNG
>>T WEANHAO T T F YNKOU
OR
JO UININGS TSHI ENING AND
UK ANYOLL AF OOU Y FOR TINUNG
ANDELE PASHE C OCKUR WSIEBTE
R MAAT GNYREAL FL PMIGRROAMNG
ANDHI WISNGONVE ERYERAEL CEBNGTI
VA HYERPY